I'm an Thornton vice provost and
university librarian here at Columbia
and I am honored to welcome all of you
to Columbia University where we are
extremely proud to host this afternoon's
award ceremony for the fourth annual
Edward M Kennedy prize for drama
inspired by American history first
please join me in acknowledging
ambassador Jean Kennedy Smith for
establishing this award in her brother's
honor as well as several other members
of the Kennedy family who we are very
pleased to have with us today in
particular I'd like to recognize the
late Kennedy senator Kennedy's son
Edward Kennedy jr. who we will hear from
later in the program
the prize honors the late senators love
of theater and his profound interest in
American history it is awarded annually
to a new play or musical than enlists
theaters power to explore the past of
the United States and participate
meaningfully and the great issues of our
day through public conversation a group
of twenty nominators selected from drama
and theatre professionals from around
the country submits recommendations to a
panel of judges who decide on the
winning piece the prize brings with it
winnings of $100,000 as well as an
original print by Jamie Wyeth who is
here with us today as well
and the prize is announced each year on
February 22nd the anniversary of Senator
Kennedy's birth I want to thank and
acknowledge the panel of judges and
nominators whose recommendations were
considered the combination of high
intellect and passionate opinion would
have made senator Kennedy proud and the
same can be said of the exceptional work
that emerged as the winning selection we
know that the late Senator Kennedy would
be tickled and pretty proud that this
year we award the prize to a musical for
the first time we are thrilled to extend
our congratulations to this year's
winning composer lyricist and book
writer Lynne Whitman well Miranda for
his exceptional Hamilton
as you'll see momentarily when we watch
a film about Senator Kennedy's life's
work the Kennedy children were taught
that the happiness of a society depends
to some degree on a deep understanding
of our country's history and a thriving
cultural landscape ambassador Smith's
creation of this prize the largest for
dramatic writing in America
will ensure that Senator Kennedy's
lifelong love of history the arts and
public service remain firmly in his
legacy finally there are many people
here who have been responsible for
making a reality of ambassador Smith's
desire to celebrate her brother's love
of the Arts
I must warmly thank the people for
today's event and for all the work
leading up to today who have brought
this prize into its fourth year first
board member and Columbia University
alumnus Tony Kushner who very much
wishes he could be with us here today
has been and will continue to be an
indispensable force in building momentum
generating excitement and providing
leadership for this prize along with
tawny board member Mandy Hackett has
spent a great deal of time since the
inception of the prize enthusiastically
leading our board and governance and
process Thank You Mandy
there are many many people to thank and
I do want to acknowledge just two more
two outstanding staff members of the
libraries Mimi and Morales and Alice and
Mauro whose hard work and dedication to
all aspects of administering the prize
and the production of this event is
truly commendable and lastly thank you
to the entire Columbia University here
with us today for being such a welcoming
and supportive environment for this
prize
thank you that which we are we are one
equal temper of heroic hearts and will
to strive to seek to find and not to
yield
for all those whose cares have been our
concern the work goes on the cause and
doors the hope still lives and the dream
shall never die
no matter who writes the history books
when people look back on this century
they will say that Edward Kennedy was
one of the ablest and most productive
most compassionate and most effective
men who served in the United States
Senate in the entire history of the
country my father loved this country and
was fascinated by the men and women who
helped to shape its history whenever he
felt the need to better understand an
issue he often looked back to how others
had solved similar problems he loved
historical documents and biographies
their perspective helped him gain
understanding not only of their time but
of our own Abe Lincoln was a quiet and a
melancholy man
but when he spoke of democracy this is
what he said he said as I would not be a
slave so I would not be a monster
this expresses my idea of democracy
whatever difference from this to the
extents of the difference is no
democracy
and welcome my grandmother
Rose Fitzgerald Kennedy gave tours of
her home in Hyannis Port yeah it's a
very charming little picture our kid
with his father at the Embassy looking
very serious who and a wonderful round
of the president late President
Roosevelt a tradition my father followed
giving tours of his office at Jamie
Wyatt like Grandma he could narrate our
nation's history from an extraordinary
point of view picture of President
Kennedy and the dog tags that he was
wearing in the Pacific my father wanted
to make history come alive
he created the annual family history
camping trip
he packed up all of my cousins and took
us on trips to visit famous American
sites in the company of historians a
senator Kennedy has been taking his
nieces and nephews and many of his
family to historic places year after
year
it's a wonderful family tradition it
ought to be a family tradition
everywhere because those trips can
change your life he took us to Plymouth
in the south shore the homes of
Nathaniel Hawthorne and Herman Melville
in the Berkshires Paul Revere and
Longfellow housed the Freedom Trail the
USS Constitution the Brooklyn Bridge
Harpers Ferry Manassas Mount Vernon Fort
McHenry and a church in Richmond after
senator Kennedy's most recent visit
we're Patrick Henry made his famous
speech
Ted nearly tackled me on the Senate
floor the next week to tell me about it
and how exciting it it was to him and
and to the members of his family he
can't insist that every child is going
to develop a love of history or an
understanding but we sure can do
everything we can to give an opportunity
for the young people
his love of American history and his
place in it is treasured by our family
but his contributions to celebrating and
preserving our history is his lasting
gift to all Americans my brother Edward
Moore Kennedy was the last of my mother
and father's nine children
right from the start he captured our
attention my mother had an insatiable
interest in history literature in the
arts and she taught and quizzed each of
us about what she thought was important
mother required Teddy to memorize the
poem the midnight ride
Paul Revere she felt that longfellows
poem was a wonderful way for her
children to learn about poetry and
history at the same time listen my
children and you shall hear of the
midnight ride of Paul Revere on the 18th
of April in 75 hardly a man is now alive
who remembers that famous day and year
teddy always said that early exposure to
our nation's history and literature had
an immeasurable impact on his life an
avid reader of biographies he authored
his own true compass as well as several
others including a children's book and
how laws are made as told through the
eyes of his beloved dog splash he
admired the visual arts and was an
accomplished painter who shared his work
with friends and family
music was perhaps dearest to him a gift
from our grandfather honey Fitz and our
mother Ted as you know singing sweet
Adeline I used to play for him on this
piano
are you
Teddy and I shared an enjoyment of
theater
especially for him musical theater he
admired the discipline and skilled a
theater demanded of actors directors and
writers he was intrigued by the theaters
creation of worlds based on the human
imagination either for the purposes of
escaping was difficult in life offer the
purposes of confronting difficult truths
he loved the creative community and the
feeling was mutual he was an ardent
student of American history and of
course he devoted his life to public
service for over 40 years in the United
States Senate he championed the role of
the arts the humanities and the
promotion of our cultural life as
integral to the American experience
Teddy could have done anything with his
life and so he chose to do everything we
are all the better for it
good afternoon I'm Bob McKay hey I'm
acting as the house historian like I
teach here at Columbia in the corner
first of all I'd like to thank the
Edward Kennedy family for endowing the
prize and the University Librarian and
Thornton for inviting me like Aaron Burr
I like to be in the room where it
matters
I'll take the expected stance of the
historian with respect to the artistic
honoree that is I'm supposed to
compliment him in this case him for
making history accessible to the non
historians without taking too many
liberties with what is after all our
material
I'll show you how that works
said historian mildly reproves said
artist when he does violence to the
historical record actually that's not an
easy task with this instance but there
are a couple when mr. Miranda has
Lafayette joining Hercules Mulligan and
Alexander Hamilton
in some downtown carousing that's
probably consistent with the record but
to have the Marquis de Lafayette as
wingman that's a real reach
still much can be forgiven and envied
and indeed admired for anyone who finds
a rhyme to the line of credit and it
turns out to be financial diuretic but I
feel obliged here not to reverse the
pattern this is more like how the
artists informed and teaches we
historians to be sure you've had some
preliminary help with a wonderful
biography by Ron chernow a brilliant and
disruptive biographer but his insights
were limited to the text to the page to
some 108 some 800 of them with you it's
two hours of music dance costuming
casting pacing and the glorious language
play George the Third's da da da which
any historian attempting would be
instantly excommunicated yet how better
to convey royal melancholy and insanity
than the way you did it with concision
indeed I think that's the most striking
element of the play example the opening
of the second act
Jefferson is introduced to us really
just back to Monticello with a letter
from George Washington waiting for him
calling him up to New York Sally bill
and darling won't you open it how much
of the historical record has been
written by historians of slavery or
biographies Oh Jefferson and don't get
it that right that quickly there are
lots of instances of this
how a Moulton clerking for the cruise
and Christians did that hub of the 18th
century Atlantic world or the failed
negotiations he had with President
Witherspoon at Princeton to see if he
could jump a class or two or the failed
negotiation or the excuse me the heroics
of Yorktown for Hamilton's over-the-top
performance at the Constitutional
Convention his role in the Federalist
Papers his hand in the in the farewell
address in the 1800 election and the
gunplay at Weehawken
and then there's yours there's his but
also your women until now I think the
Revolutionary period had been largely a
guys event and males only smoker if you
will largely limited on the distaff side
to Abigail Adams I think it was Barack
Obama I know it was Barack Obama when
asked in 2008 what he thought of Hillary
Clinton as opponent I liked her all
right that's been my view of Abigail
Adams pretty much till now
but the scylla sisters are another story
altogether
Angelica whom Hamilton loved and longed
for but also Eliza whom he married and
missed and sought forgiveness from and
she on her part who stayed behind for
another half century to see that her
husband was well cared for both Angelica
and Eliza able to forgive him for his
don't know how to say no to this the
reconciliation that comes in the second
act is way beyond Tammy Wynette's stand
by her man enough though of the many
small greatnesses of your Hamilton on to
the big one it's an act a momentous
restoration and redirection most of the
founding fathers we know had
multi-generational claims to their
Americanists they were among the
colonial first arrivals whether the
Quincy's of the Madison are the Quincy's
that were the Adams from Massachusetts
The Jeffersons or the Randalls from
Virginia the Morrises of the Jays from
New York or even Aaron Burr from New
York and New Jersey all long off the
boat
among the arrives and not needing a
revolution to be somebody they already
were they were part of the colonial
aristocracy and then nearly all of them
got to grow old and honored Jefferson
and Adams fighting it out as to who
would make it to 1826 the sickly James
Madison making it to 85
and you're Alexander Hamilton a founding
father for the most of us for the rest
of us those up from the islands from the
other shores or my Kellogg my colleague
Mary Gordon at Barnard refers to us as
the other side like him
immigrants somewhat who we didn't choose
coming in this instance to the greatest
city in the world up from the islands in
Hamilton's case the walls of nevus and
st. Kitts but there are other islands
Ireland itself County Limerick Edward
Kennedy's maternal grandfather's
beginnings or his maternal great
grandfather's beginnings in Konya
Wexford or Vega altar in Puerto Rico
where your father are coming from and on
in the instance of Puerto Rico for whom
you made a wonderful op-ed editorial in
the last week but there are other
islands Aloha Hawaii other places that
are islands Aleppo Kabul both of them
even in my own case grandparents from
Coney Tyrone by way of Rhode Island
Pawtucket specifically those of you
unfamiliar with Pawtucket particularly
the New Yorkers it's like Yonkers
without the glitz
mr. Miranda thank you for delivering as
a founding father for our day for the
21st century a believable aspirational
vision of ourselves at our best
I find it uh pleading uplifting in
downbeat times it's in the spoken
tradition of the 17th century John
Winthrop antennas model of Christian
charity charity his city upon a hill for
the 18th pens common sense pains common
sense or even Jefferson's Declaration of
Independence for the 19th it's Lincoln
picked just about anything he wrote for
the 20th FDR's first inaugural but also
Martin Luther King's I had a dream and
perhaps Barack Obama has quoted to it
the Joshua generation it's in the
musical tradition of Francis Scott Key's
star-spangled banner' or Julia Ward Howe
has battled him in the Republic or even
Captain Lee Bates America the Beautiful
I think the Ray Charles a vision or its
Irving Berlin's God Bless America and
here you have a wide choice
Miriam Anderson Kate Smith Shakira
you choose I think they all would
portray a young scrappy and hungry just
like my own country I think you'll and
your play is the first is this century's
first claimant to inclusion in this
heady category the American Songbook but
it's still early in the century and
you're still young so keep on truckin
keep on rapping keep up the stage magic
that you do thank you very much
hi everyone my name is Mandy Hackett and
I have the pleasure of serving on the
board of the prize as we saw from the
video
senator Kennedy certainly had a
particularly American musical so every
year when we put together this ceremony
we like to include a couple of musical
selections this year we have invited the
incredible young people's chorus of New
York City to share with us some
selections of a musical I know when you
hold near and dear to your heart
please welcome thank you
they see
Oh
Wow what an incredible performance
an incredible tribute Westside story was
one of my father's favorite musicals of
all time but it was hard for him to pick
his favorite so I'm Ted Kennedy jr. and
on behalf of the entire Kennedy family
welcome to the awarding of the Edward M
Kennedy Prize for drama inspired by
American history
I just I'm very emotional today I have
to say that uh I miss my father so much
because I know how much he would have
loved this year's Prize winner my dad he
he loved history you saw in the video he
packed us all up in his rented camper or
bus and you know every year to take us
to the Civil War monuments to the places
of the American Revolution and he loved
the characters that shaped our nation
and he dedicated his life to to to
public service he had a copy of the
Federalist Papers on his bookshelf by
his bed and you know he also had a
passion for the Arts he was an
accomplished painter many of his friends
were actors and painters and artists and
and and he had a very close friendship
with you Jamie thank you so much for
being here and for your contributions to
this award he he loved artists not just
because I think he loved and admired
their talent but because he knew that
and was fascinated by their ability to
transport us to a deeper understanding
of our common human experience artists
made make us think they make us laugh
and but most people assume that the job
my father aspired to the one that he
never attained was president of the
United States but that's not true my
fall way my father's always secretly
wanted to become a Broadway musical
theater star
and you saw him with belting out a few
tunes on the video but gene by
establishing this award
you may dad's dream come true your hard
work your generosity the consent
conceiving of this prize and working
with with Tony and developing it is a
incredibly special gift to our family
and to the country thank you so much for
all of that you did
to Columbia University thank you once
again for hosting us here and of course
to you lin-manuel congratulations we're
so proud to honor you here today becomes
a special source of pride as a fellow
Wesleyan alumnus with your musical
theater abilities and your
groundbreaking presentation and creation
of Hamilton we're all in awe and
recognize you today you've made history
come alive and Hamilton all makes us all
want to learn more about history and who
the founding fathers were and their
humanity and their vulnerabilities and
how they shaped our country and these
are the exact lessons that my father
tried to teach me and you've done it for
all of us thank you and congratulations
and now we get closer to the prize
itself as you can imagine from today's
ceremony it is truly an honor and a
privilege for me to sit on the board of
the prize by design the prize encourages
today's writers to engage with our
history and in doing so it allows all of
us through the power of the theater to
look back at our past and understanding
our world today Jean it's in pursuit of
this and through your leadership and
your commitment and your vision that you
are such an inspiration to me and I know
to all of us who are connected to the
prize and I'd like to invite you now to
please come join me
oh dear I have to say my co-chair Tony
Kushner who usually joins joining me on
stage for the presentation of the prize
is on a film set in Pittsburgh this
morning and I am very annoyed with him
very the Edwin F Kennedy prize is given
annually through Columbia University to
a new play or musical of merit that
enlists theaters power to explore the
past to the United States to participate
meaningfully meaningfully in the great
issues of the day
through the public conversation grounded
and historical understanding that is
essential to the functioning of
democracy
I wrote that it sounds just like me
doesn't it bandit
you can come back you're done done done
speaking but not done off the stage yet
whoops
the board would also like to thank
Columbia University particularly and
Thornton who's new with us for the first
time this year we're looking forward to
many wonderful years of the prize ahead
together and our special thanks to
minion morales and allison morrow as
well we would also like to thank our
panel of distinguished judges
playwrights Christopher Diaz Mona
Mansoor Dominique Morris oh and Washburn
composer Jeanine Tesori librettist and
playwright John Weidman and Columbia
University Professors Farah Jasmine
Griffin Rashid Khalidi and James Shapiro
our nominators selected for
extraordinary plays and one
extraordinary musical as the finalists
for the 2016 Kennedy prize they are an
octoroon by Brandon Jacobs Jenkins
indecent by Paula Vogel sweat by Lynn
Nottage vehicon by kini yen and Hamilton
by Lin Manuel Miranda there are three
components to the prize a bursary award
of $100,000 a website devoted to the
prize-winning play were Musical accept
accessible to teachers and students
interested in an in-depth exploration of
the plays content subject matter and
production history and each recipient of
the prize also receives a print of a
glorious painting by artist Jamie Wyeth
of the Senator Ted Kennedy schooner Maya
commissioned for the fries by ambassador
Smith this year for the first time with
all that mr. Wyeth is joining us in the
presentation of the prize and finally
Tony who truly is very sorry
today I've spoken to him several times
this morning starting at about 7:30 this
morning when I was trying to get my kids
to school and he is truly very sorry not
to be here today but he has asked the
amazing the brilliant the indispensable
chris hayes of MSNBC's all in with chris
hayes to step in for him today as our
presenter Chris please join us alright
so you don't you don't get one of the
most brilliant writers and dramatists of
our time you instead get a talking head
and for that I apologize it is a bit of
a letdown I will be completely honest
and we're I in your shoes I would be
pretty annoyed as well I think Tony
asked me to do this because I am lucky
enough to have had the good fortune of
knowing Lynn for 25 years Lynn and I met
when we were 12 and 13 respectively
doing theater at Hunter College High
School we were in a play together he
played an old Jewish man and I played a
kind of jerky young husband who threw a
stapler out the window and killed
someone swing what Swingline 4:57 Lynn
and I were both Lynn lived in Inwood I
live in the Bronx we would take the
Express bus in and out together we would
stay for Laura her CIL's we were both
outer Burroughs drivers for lack of a
better word even though he was in the
borough but it might as well been the
outer borough and so I got to recognize
and I'm saying this 100% crossed my
heart honestly that I was dealing with a
genius when I was 13 100%
he wrote a musical his first musical I
think I got to direct when I was a
senior it was called nightmare in D
major
it featured a reverie in which the
dissected pig fetus from a biology class
came back to haunt the protagonist
wielding a knife back at him
I can still hum tunes from that it was
brilliant then 20 minutes I directed him
I also have had the good fortune I had
the very very good fortune of seeing
Hamilton very very early and the reason
that I say very very good fortune was
it's one of the rare things in life that
something that's so celebrated and hyped
can still manage to live up to what it
has been hyped as which is the rare
thing Hamilton is but I also got to see
it without all of that build-up when
invited me to a workshop on the west
side I had seen the first two numbers of
the show the first number at the white
house the second number he performed on
my show actually when I had a Sunday
morning show so I went there and I
thought well I'm very excited this will
be great and I went during the middle of
my workday I perform I have a show at
8:00 p.m. tonight and every night so I
almost never do this I went over there
in the middle of the afternoon and I saw
this thing and I had to go back to work
afterwards it was like 6 o'clock at that
point and there were a few things that
happened one was I was walking down the
street googling all this stuff on
Wikipedia because I just thought he'd
made it up like did Hamilton really
write about his affairs in a pan like is
that a thing he made up that can't be an
actual thing was his son was killed no
this is all ridiculous so I'm sort of
walking and I'm googling and then I I
literally I was so overcome that I sat
down on a stoop and I saw the time
ticking by cuz I knew I had to get back
and I was gonna the green light was
gonna come on at 8:00 but it actually
precipitated like a very profound
existential crisis I just thought like
what am I doing with my life
like literally what am I doing with my
life both in comparison to Alexander
Hamilton and comparison this dude I've
known for 25 years like what the hell do
I have to show for my time on earth and
I think one of the most remarkable
effects a piece of art can have is to
precipitate that to take the ordinary
world and break it down to break down
what is mundane into some set of
constituent pieces that you the the
audience have to try to put back
together again and I think what makes
this place so powerful what has had such
this remarkable sort of effect on
everyone who's come in contact with it
is that it it calls us to be great in
the way that democracy calls us to be
great because the fundamental principle
democracy is that every single person is
capable of the greatness of
self-determination that there are no
lords and masters and that there are no
kings and then each of us has within us
the soul of a citizen and that the soul
of the citizen is a truly great thing
that we each can unleash and so if
America's Civic religion is democracy
Hamilton has become its most ecstatic
mass and for that I think we're all
grateful thank you Lynne
come on up here buddy
okay
I'll give this to my dad to hold him
okay um hi I have been told that act two
of Hamilton is is unfairly sad and it
makes people feel all the feelings and
if today was your brutal revenge upon me
consider it accomplished beginning with
a reception upstairs where I was shown
by the amazing people here at Columbia
University in their archives Hamilton
and Eliza's wedding bands
Hamilton's enrollment papers here at
King's College Hamilton's son Phillips
enrollment here at King's College
now Columbia and Hamilton's final letter
to Eliza written on the morning of his
duel with Burr so I was a mess before I
even walked in here getting to see those
primary documents then you hit me with
the incredible words of our historian
who puts me an incredible heady company
and I'm really honored Robert thank you
so much for that and you bring out the
young people's chorus of New York City
to sing the selections beautifully to
sing the selections of the musical that
is probably the reason I'm standing here
it's as if you brought out Citizen Kane
and then just brought out 50 sleds
it said here look so I'm a mess from
that then you have the beautiful tribute
to mr. Kennedy and his life's work and
his duet with Stokes then you bring out
my friend Chris Hayes who I first met
because I took the wrong bus home via
the bus was supposed to stop at two a
seventh Street before it went into the
Bronx was my first time on the bus and I
didn't get on the right bus and there I
am lost in the Bronx and probably
looking like this and Chris has he got a
hunter right did you get on the wrong
bus he was sitting across from me and
let me go to his house and call my
mother and that's how we met so to then
have him come speak I am so overcome by
this incredible honor that notion of
what am I doing with my life hit me
first when I picked up Ron chair now is
incredible biography it begins there and
in seeing Hamilton's relentlessness his
first letter to his friend Ned Stephens
he says I may be building castles in the
air' but my ambition is prevalent and we
have seen such schemes successful when
the projector is constant I'm never
gonna write like that to be 14 years old
and writing to your best friend I gotta
get out of here it deeply related to
that and I saw in it not just my father
who left Puerto Rico at 18 to get an
education in New York just like Hamilton
but so many of the people I grew up with
I grew up in an immigrant neighborhood
and we just knew the rule was you're
gonna have to work twice as hard and so
when I found that out about Hamilton I
said I know this guy I know this guy and
he's not gonna let me go and he didn't
let me go for seven years and in
learning his story I learned the story
of Eliza Hamilton and I learned what
unconditional love really is really is
and it is a love story it is it's not
the West Side Story we fall in love in
six lines and we died two days later
it's the we're gonna endure the hardest
things Humanity is going to throw at us
and we're gonna forgive each other
anyway and we're gonna love each other
anyway and when you're gone I'm gonna
tell your story as long as I live and
that's what the lies that did for
Alexander that's what the Kennedys had
done for their father grandfather and
brother and friend and I am honored
beyond belief to get this award I'm
incredible company the suzan-lori parks
and Dominic Moore so who I used to teach
fourth graders with in Woodhaven Queens
there's a link between teaching and
writing teaching it's the opposite of
performing in a way you learned that
when you Bhagat was a seventh grade
English teacher it's my first job at
college and what you learn is when
you're really doing your job you're not
performing you are stepping back and you
are keeping the ball in the air while
these kids learn and it's the most
incredible thing to watch them teach
each other
and all you have to do is add a few
ingredients and their brilliant minds
are gonna take care of the rest so I
didn't know it at the time but Hamilton
is an extension of that here's the story
and and what I'm excited for and it's
already happening with this educational
program we're doing with the Rockefeller
Foundation and the Gilder Lehrman
foundation is the other takeaway from
Hamilton is history so subjective the
teller of it determines it and you know
Ron chernow will tell you about the
first time we met and he will tell you
that I sang him Alexander Hamilton and I
will tell you I sang my shot because
that's how I remember it
that was four years ago that's how a
subjective history is the teller
determines the reality and the victor
often determines the reality
and I'm excited to see what stories come
out of this and what comes next and I'm
unbelievably overwhelming today so thank
you so much to the board thank you so
much to the Kennedys and thank you so
much for having me here tonight thank
you very much
and Men well I want to thank you and
your family again for joining us today
and once again extend warm
congratulations on behalf of the prize
and the Columbia University community
we can't wait to see what's next for you
I hope you will all join us for a
reception downstairs to celebrate
continue celebrating and to enjoy one
another it's accessible from the stairs
or the elevator just outside the rear
doors thank you very very much